اعلان عن هذه الحكومه او هذه تشكيل
الحكوميه الاسرائيليه الجديده التي ربما
تضم ايضا شخصيات يا ميديا مو متطرف اي
المخاوف والاصداء على هداء التشكيل سواء
في همم في القدس او من الجانب الفلسطيني
هل تشرح حكومه بنيامين ثانيه اهو على
تنفيذ هذه الوعود والتعهدات على راسها همم
اعاده فرد وبسط السياده الاسرائيليه على
الضفه الغربيه وهذه تعني اعاده همم احتلال
الضفه الغربيه وعوده الوجود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
الرسمي في المؤسسات في الامور الحياتيه
للفلسطينيين داخل مدن وقرى ومخيمات الضفه
الغربيه هل هناك لهذه الحكومه ربما تكون
هذه التساؤلات الكبرى الفلسطينيين لتنفيذ
هذه القضيه هناك تعويل فلسطين على مساله
هل تقوى الحكومه الاسرائيليه على التكافل
بالمستلزمات الماديه للامور الحياتيه
الفلسطينيه الاجابه اعت ان في هذه الناحيه
اا قد تكون نعم على اعتبار ان التمويل
المادي الان لمثل هذه الحكومه نعلم نتناه
لديه شبكه علاقات كبيره جدا هو من وضع سكر
قطار التطبيع مع دول خليجيه في مكانها
وبدا هذه العمليه ولربما قد تكون هناك 400
مساله همم محاوله استغلال هذه العلاقات من
قبل بني امنتنياهو سياسيه اقتصاديا
وبتبيعه الحال في كل هذه النواحي اعتقد ان
هذه القضيه قد تكون مرتبطه بمدى جراتنا
تناهى لتنفيذ هذه الشكر للعود كانت في
القدس على كل هذه التفاصيل شكرا لك